I love to watch science fiction movies
but I cringe I cringe whenever I see a
depiction of the aliens first of all the
aliens speak perfect English not just
British English they speak perfect
American English and obviously there are
human inside some kind of monkey suit I
mean we have Hollywood special effects
right so why can't we get better aliens
and then the aliens think just like us
they're territorial they want to conquer
they want resources they want they see
humans as inferior but you see that's
only a byproduct of our evolution look
at other animals in the animal kingdom
some animals are not territorial ok they
don't have to conquer
we have other paradigms in the animal
kingdom which are totally different from
the way our brain is constructed but
when we look at aliens in the movies
we're basically projecting our own
consciousness in aliens our fears our
desires are projected and they are a
mirror of who we are not a mirror of who
they really are for example if you take
a look at a bat or a dog the dog's brain
is mainly interested in smells it's
swirling in a universe of smells while a
bats brain meaning is concentrated on
sonar on detecting clicks and echoes
same thing with the dolphin brain their
consciousness is totally different from
our consciousness because they see
things differently than us because of
their evolutionary history for example
when we see a cat and the cat comes up
to us and press tapper next to us we say
to ourselves all nice cat cat is being
affectionate no the cat is not being
affectionate is simply rubbing his
hormones on you and saying I own this
human this human is mine I'm marking my
territory this huge this human feeds me
twice a day I've trained him so a cat
sees the universe totally different than
we
and yet we impose our thinking on an
alien now on the question of
intelligence if these aliens are more
intelligent than us how would they be
more intelligent in the book I say that
one of the main ingredients of
intelligence is to predict the future
the ability to simulate today so we see
tomorrow and that requires a high level
of intelligence to be able to understand
the laws of nature the laws of people
what is the most likely outcome of a
future event that requires intelligence
if they are more intelligent than us
they will see the future much better
than us they will see outcomes that we
cannot foresee they will simulate
scenarios that we cannot even dream of
they can outwit us every time think of a
safecracker
a safecracker may have a low IQ may have
dropped out of elementary school but the
safecracker can simulate the future much
better than a cop can and that's why he
can rob banks and get away with it so in
other words the criminal mind is not
necessarily stupid because it has low IQ
it's quite well adapted for what it does
and what it does is to simulate the
future of a crime now think of what when
we encounter intelligent life that is
more intelligent than us they may see
the world totally differently their
world may be a world of smells a world
of sounds rather than a world of
eyesight like our brain is constructed
and most important they may be able to
see the outcome of future events much
better than us they'll be able to
actually run circles around us because
they see the future
you